Want to see something really scary?
The horror genre is especially fertile ground
for Easter eggs, because it's always unnerving
to discover something hiding in plain sight.
Here are a few particularly ominous Easter
eggs hidden in some of your favorite horror
films.
Potential spoilers ahead!
Many people consider 1973's The Exorcist to
be one of the finest horror films ever made.
Sure, some of the scares and effects might
not pack the same punch they once did…particularly
after decades of parody and imitations.
Nevertheless, The Exorcist still manages to
unnerve audiences all these years later.
To add to the unease, director William Friedkin
included all sorts of subliminal sounds and
images.
Speaking with Entertainment Weekly, he discussed
layering sounds deep into the film's mix,
like the buzzing of bees.
Friedkin hoped such these effects would trigger
an unconscious fight-or-flight response in
the viewer.
To that end, Friedkin also inserted a frightening
face into a few shots, and they're just fast
enough for you to register that something
freaky is afoot.
Sure, the face looks a lot less impressive
once you get a close look at it…but thanks
to some stealth editing, it's an admittedly
creepy effect.
John Carpenter's The Thing features some impressive
practical creature effects and a slow burn
plot that still has people questioning the
ending.
This '80s cult classic stars Kurt Russell
as a helicopter pilot fighting against a shapeshifting
alien on a remote base camp in Antarctica.
Yes, it's as awesome as it sounds.
The thrills come from watching the dwindling
research team try to determine which of their
supposed peers is actually the creature.
That's no small feat, considering the alien
can mimic anything it touches.
Here's the thing, though: If they'd known
how to speak Norweigan, the team could've
avoided their predicament altogether.
At the beginning of the film, a dog runs towards
the team, and a clearly traumatized man is
trying to shoot the creature.
He's passionately shouting something, but
it's not in a language that any of the researchers
understand.
[speaking Norwegian]
According to some translations, the man is
shouting something along the lines of:
"Get the hell outta there.
That's not a dog, it's some sort of thing!
It's imitating a dog, it isn't real!
Get away, you idiots!"
They probably wouldn't have believed him anyway...but
it's still rather chilling to know the plot
is all laid out in the film's opening moments.
The 2004 horror film Saw totally cleaned up
at the box office, earning almost 100 times
its $1.2 million budget.
The reveal of Jigsaw's identity is a real
shocker, but eagle-eyed fans could've figured
it out much sooner if they noticed one subtle
detail.
Early on in the film, we meet one of Dr. Gordon's
cancer patients, a fellow by the name of John
Kramer.
At one point, we see Kramer resting in his
hospital bed, and savvy viewers might have
noticed an intriguing drawing on a page of
his sketchbook.
Yes, it's a drawing of the infamous "reverse
bear trap"…you know the one.
The sketch is a nice touch that's sure to
appeal to obsessive horror fans.
Life is all about enjoying the little things...isn't
it?
"Most people are so ungrateful to be alive."
Pennywise the Dancing Clown is creepy no matter
how you slice it, both in Stephen King's gargantuan
horror novel It, and in the stellar two-part
film adaptation.
In fact, the movie includes one particularly
chilling detail from King's novel: Pennywise
can change the color of his eyes at will.
Considering all the other things he's capable
of, like, you know, transforming into a physical
manifestation of your greatest fear, this
might not seem like such a big deal.
It's why he does it that really makes your
skin crawl.
At the beginning of It: Chapter One, Georgie
has a famously ill-fated encounter with Pennywise…and
you might have noticed that the clown's eyes
suddenly change from yellow to blue.
That comes directly from a passage of King's
novel:
"There were yellow eyes in there: the sort
of eyes he had always imagined but never actually
seen down in the basement."
A few paragraphs later, King writes,
"How, George wondered, could I have thought
his eyes were yellow?
They were a bright, dancing blue, the color
of his mom's eyes."
Pennywise realizes Georgie is about to run
away, so he changes the color of his eyes
to mirror Georgie's loved ones, therefore
putting the boy at ease.
How insidious of him.
"Popcorn!
Is that your favorite?"
"Uh huh."
"Mine too.
Because they pop."
The Conjuring 2 plays a fun game of peek-a-boo
throughout the film: the demon's name Valak
is subtly sprinkled throughout various scenes,
always hidden somewhere in the background.
For instance, it's written here on the kitchen
wall.
The 'V' comes from the "Love" knickknack sitting
on top.
It's also here, on the bookshelf, there are
five wooden letters spread out across the
shelves.
The next time you check out The Conjuring
2, you're cordially invited to play a game
we like to call "Where's Valak?"
For instance, you can also see the name spelled
out in the beaded necklace Lorraine's daughter
is making.
Let's see if you can spot it.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
horror movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.